- Hey, guys, my name is Heinrich
and welcome to Firm Learning.
I'm a little bit excited
because this is my very
first video on this channel
and I would like to use
it as an introduction
of what you can expect if
you subscribe to my channel
and look at all the future
videos that I'm going to upload.
I'm Heinrich, I'm from Germany
and my passion has always
been business and management.
I would like to use this channel
to reflect on my experiences
and share what I have
learned in the last years.
My professional background
is management consulting.
I've worked for over six years
for a large, leading, top
management consulting firm
and now recently transitioned
to a role in industry,
now working for a large
German fashion retailer.
This channel is going to
be especially targeted
towards new people just
being in the labor market
for a couple of years,
young professionals,
or people who are going to join
the very first job they're
going to have very soon.
Some things I will cover are,
for example, meeting behavior.
How can I behave at the
very best in the meeting
if I'm only a junior colleague?
Or having tough conversations
with some other work colleagues
or maybe even my boss.
Or what to do if you
make a mistake at work,
what to do about it, how to do that.
But also topics covering mindset issues
and other things that might hold you back
in order to be successful in your career.
Before working, I studied
business and philosophy
here in Munich but also in other
universities across Europe.
These have been some pretty
formative years for me as well
which will also heavily
influenced how I see things,
what my perception is,
what perspective I have that
I want to bring across to you.
Besides all of this,
I would also like to use
this channel as a playground
to learn about social
media, learn about YouTube
and other platforms like that,
so hanging with me here, let's
not take this too seriously,
I'm sharing a few thoughts
and hopefully we are all
gonna learn from that.
Of course, I'm very much
open for your suggestions.
I would like to hear from you
what topics around these things
you would be interested in,
ask me question, set me up via email
or in the comments below
and of course subscribe to this channel
to not miss out any opportunity.
Of course, over time I will also work
on improving the equipment
to make this a more
professional experience
for everybody involved,
so hang in there here with me as well,
the audio quality will improve over time.
Thank you for watching
this very first video.
I will be posting new videos
soon so let's get started.